dans bourdin direct sur rmc découverte
on a appris que des parents vegan
s'était vu retirer la garde de leur bébé
un bébé de cinq mois pour cause de
malnutrition vous écouter et on s'en
parle juste après ses parents ne le
nourrit sec avec de la pomme de terre
écrasées nous sommes aux états unis en
californie ce couple voulait élever
leurs enfants conformément à leurs
convictions ils sont allés voir un
médecin qui leur a fourni des menus
détails et ça leur a pas plu ils ont
donc opté pour cette recette de pommes
de terre écrasées et cinq mois après la
naissance le bébé n'avait pris que deux
cents grammes
il pesait 3 kilos et demi quand les
services sociaux ont dénoncé les parents
d'irriter les parents sont en prison le
bébé est à l'hôpital il va beaucoup
mieux
il a pris cinq cents grammes déjà alors
bout'chou qui n'a pris que deux cents
grammes en cinq mois
visiblement les parents ça les alertes
pas du tout ils vont quand même au
départ faire moi ce que je pense bien
c'est à dire aller demander un médecin
comment éventuellement pouvoir être en
accord avec laure la place nous offrir
se voir la nourriture et ils suivent pas
et suivent pas ce que dit le médecin
c'est à dire que le médecin préconise
quelque chose et eux non damien qu'est
ce que vous en pensez voilà
l'illustration en fait de la folie de
certains vegan extrémistes qui au nom
d'une idéologie extrême et surtout très
sectaire met en danger en fait la vie de
leurs enfants parce que ces personnes
moi j'espère qu'elles seront condamnés à
une peine de prison extrêmement lourde
elles ont mis leurs enfants en danger
surtout leurs enfants risquent d'avoir
des séquelles psychiques et scié faille
physique ensuite par la suite quand
est-ce que tout simplement parce que là
on pointe du doigt le fait qu'il soit
vegan est-ce que simplement c'est pas
des parents dégâts nous pavé gagnent
tout et ça m'est arrivé
vous avez lu mon livre vous le savez ça
m'est arrivé j'étais placé pendant 18
mois je veux dire mais 18 premiers mois
on m'a nourri que de ça de pommes de
terre de bouillie curé de demain voilà
aucune fibre gtdi forme mais carrément
difformes
je suis allé dans une chaise une très
bonne nourrissent et deux mois après ça
y est j'ai été regardée voilà qui vous a
comblé non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il faut pas pointer du doigt
les vegans là pour le coup moi j'ai
aussi une sympathique non mais non là
c'est juste des parents tonnes c'est de
la maltraitance puisque comme vous
l'avez dit on leur avait recommandé un
programme de voilà donc
franchement c'est pas les beckham sont
en cause il faut pointer du doigt ces
personnes qui ont recours à des régimes
vegan pour des enfants en bas âge qui
ont besoin d'apports nutritionnels
vachement important
je suis désolé un régime vegan quand on
est enfant c'est criminel il ne faut pas
masquer un enfant au delà de ce cas
typique de maltraitance ce cas là vous
vous dites de toute façon quand on a des
enfants ont ils n'ont pas avoir de
régime légal mais tout à fait le régime
vegan c'est une philosophie c'est une
conception du bien être animal et c'est
pourquoi elle a posé aux enfants qui ont
vraiment des besoins très importants à
chambly dans sa chasse sachant que si on
va chez un médecin et peut
éventuellement vous écroulez comment
remplacer les premiers à la vegetal je
suis désolé mon enfant n'a rien à voir
avec le véganisme il se nourrira délais
parce que c'est la nourriture d'un
enfant de cet âge là points après on
peut avoir des conceptions vegan par la
suite en inculquant à l'enfant le bien
être l'année quel âge par exemple vous
estimez que le parent peut mais qui
étire après le col v gagnent avec 16 ans
c'est vachement ce comportement à partir
du moment où l'enfant peut varier son
alimentation peut commencer à manger des
choses solides etc
mais dès qu'il est tout petit que c'est
la petite enfance d'accord vous vous
dites quand même que des enfants
c'est-à-dire dès 7 8 9 10 ans peuvent
être à avoir un régime alimentaire mais
pourquoi pas si c'est fait effectivement
avec des diététiciens des
nutritionnistes parce qu'il faut surtout
pas se lancer dans un régime de gamme
comme ça tous avaient ludivine alors
j'avoue que le véganisme est très
tendance on entend parler que de ça mais
effectivement il y à des alternatives
moi je suis pas contre je ne peux que
j'ai essayé j'ai tenu deux jours pas de
trucs rien qu'au canada
j'aimerais si c'est pas possible pour
moi je suis même pas carnivore chimiques
cannibale donc mais je respecte
totalement effectivement c'est très
tendance
au delà des cimes effectivement qu'il
s'agit de parents maltraités sur voila
je pense qu'il l'est pas vraiment déjà
ont des petits soucis mais c'est vrai
que le véganisme permettent de belles
alternatives avec que ce soit au fustec
bord tout cas heureusement que ce petit
nourrisson qui n'a pas les moyens de se
signaler a été a été repéré parce que
dans ces cas-là on pouvait arriver à une
situation qui essuiera matic